il ya deux mois on nous expliquait que
la république en marche allait faire
main basse sur le sénat je constate que
il n'en est pas du tout question
évidemment ce soir pourquoi ce résultat
moi je pense que ça tient deux choses
d'abord le seul fait que la lune de miel
entre mm macro et les françaises se soit
terminée vous savez les grands électeurs
ils vivent au milieu de la population et
le résultat ce soir c'est le reflet
particulier pour une élection données
d'une sorte finalement de perte de
confiance vis-à-vis de l'exécutif
et puis c'est rajouter les maladresses
toutes les maladresses depuis deux mois
qui ont confiné parfois au mépris
vis-à-vis des élus locaux